e
good morning everyone oh gosh that's
loud sorry first thing Monday morning um
we're going to go ahead and start the
subcommittee on 553 um thank you for the
members for being here and for the
members of our audience and being here
um this is really to kind of wrap up
where we were we gotten a lot of
discussions this last time uh we did get
a letter from um a physician I believe
at Dartmouth um that really spoke more
to the original Bill not the how it was
supposed to be that amended version I
have not seen any statistics that we
were told or anything was going to come
did anybody else get any statistics from
anyone no
statistics just opinions yep and um we
do have I'm going to give um you all
just like a couple minutes to look so if
you look in your emails if you have it
with you but um our our committee
researcher did look at other states that
have um the uh prenatal part of it in
there and the substance abuse uh part of
that in there so we just have that can
you get that on yours um representative
Deon or do you need to borrow my
computer um it came in from Kristen
Grant um she should have just sent that
this
morning
Grant um and this is listed
all of the
um 17 states that that states yes that
do have it um most of them are not as
protective of mothers as what ours is so
um but you can go ahead and kind of look
at those I think that was one of the
time
that this is really
a strong bipartisan bill this bill
originated from Senator Carson who is of
course the Senate President that there's
no Republican or Democrat this is a
bipartisan bill that was worked on for
months correct really years and was it
weekly that that you they worked on this
last year yes so for and weekly for
months so it's not like this is just
some Fly by Night
legislation that this is has been worked
on and and is a
bipartisan
bill
um spearheaded by Senator Carson so I
just wanted to get that out there so
that people aren't thinking this is a
Democrat bill or Republican bill this is
a very responsible bipartisan
Bill to update the defin s in the child
protection
act does nothing else no there's no
criminal penalties anywhere nothing this
is just updating the child protection
act to bring us in line really with a
lot of other states that are out there
um so I just wanted
to address that thank you yeah I think
it's important to note that this has not
really been updated since 1980 since
then we have had a plethora of um
knowledge and finding as to what abuse
looks like as to what toxic uh
situations look like within families and
we also understand and we have said
multiple times in this legislature that
we do think that family is the best
place that's the best place for kids so
we want to be able to identify when
there's an issue within a family so that
we can have support for them so that
they can you know work on those things
and have ways to come together as a
healthy family so certainly right now
the way that the definitions are there's
a lot of
um vagueness as far as when DCF can step
in with
um uh interventions not to take the kids
away but just to um Provide support yeah
services and support and so we're really
at a situation where we have seen some
extreme cases where when we're hearing
about it um it's too late for the child
we certainly have had testimony of
doctors um from Dartmouth come in and
talk about babies who um have broken
bones that are not able to move or
anything and then they go back to the
parents because there's no there's
nothing in our Provisions right now that
would prevent that as a matter of fact
the way that we have it now is stated
that they do go back to their parents
nobody can say anything if there's no
finding which nobody's talking um then
that that's part of the problem we also
have a state where parents can decline
to have dcyf come in um this does not
change that either so this um simply
says that we understand that uh the
safety of children is important and this
is what we're outlining is uh we find
abuse or neglect um we do have
rebuttable presumptions of harm to make
sure that we're mitigating and not um
over penalizing parents but also I think
it's important to have updated
definitions because because not only do
we protect kids in this we actually
protect parents too if we have a deeper
understanding of what abuse is in a
modern way we're not penalizing parents
that maybe that's not abuse so um do you
have a question yeah um I just I just
want to point out um I'm just why I'm
here and and uh I'm on house criminal
justice and Public Safety and we're
considering a bill HB
257 which expand greatly expands the
criminalization of uh uh let's call it
inadequate parenting it it's entitled
it's a child neglect Bill and uh
criminalizes neglectful parenting with
some
specifics uh there is it's we're really
struggling with the bill because um I
think many on the committee believe
believe the DCF system the Civil system
is better able to manage families that
are having problems going forward than
is the criminal system uh there's a lot
more limits you know in the criminal
system and um
it's it may be that
257 doesn't need to go forward or needs
to be significantly scaled back
as the committee understands what's
going on with 553 so that's that's why
I'm here thank you I appreciate that
session and I think that um you know
you'll see within our committee our
regular committee and stuff we have a
lot of bills coming forth this year
trying to kind of attack this problem
that we see certainly um with Harmony
Montgomery and some of our other um uh
notable cases that we've seen we have
seen the breakdown of the system so we
have a lot of different bills trying to
really come at this issue of protecting
kids
I think this is the F A foundational
bill because this is what these other
bills then um get built off of this is
simply definitions um so that way then
we can um basically not have a crumbling
Foundation as to how we're protecting
kids right now we have a very outdated
and crumbling Foundation which is
leading to um a lot of bills that either
can't be followed or that are just
ineffective or um maybe too punitive as
well so we need to make sure that we
have this um foundation in there have
you guys gotten a chance to kind of look
at that and see that there are a lot of
other states that have
that
okay um just to paraphrase so last time
we did talk about uh constitutionality
of this bill um representative deimon it
is one of her jobs to make sure that it
is you know constitutional as far as
what we're doing and so um you did find
it is absolutely
constitutional
uh I found I think four three court
cases that the uh Supreme Court found it
constitutional
um people need to remember when they
talk
about the constitutionality of bills is
that
unless it is specifically stated
otherwise bills are
constitutional this bill happens to be
be a bill
where for many many years due to the
to actuality and perception
are the biggest hurdles that we face so
the
perception of what is and is not child
abuse and neglect is not always actual
it is not always specific enough so one
of the uh issues that we face right now
or questions
is so if I say to my
child that's it go to your room and
don't come out until so your room is
clean that that could be
neglect I've checked with attorneys with
judges with psychologist with
psychiatrists now that
that's a situation where on the face
absolutely
not if you say
to your child if I have to leave you in
that room for a month and you
do and you refuse to give the child food
or access to bathroom facilities or
water now we're talking a different
story but actually saying that's it go
to your room and don't come out until
it's clean or that's it go to your room
until you can change your attitude
things of that sort there it's not
emotional abuse it absolutely is not so
the Fear Factor that and I'm go I'll go
back to the media situation The Fear
Factor that the
media ends up putting out there for
people is the problem that we have
with society's perception of what is and
is not one the perception that it's
constitutional is in my opinion not
true two the perception of what is and
is not emotional abuse has
already been talked about in 13 other
states and it has already been discussed
in the courts in the past all this bill
is doing is putting a
finite list of
definitions it is not saying that if you
do this you're going to have your
children removed first of all another
perception is that um dcyf or DHHS can
walk in your house and take your
kids that's illegal to be honest with
you
um they still have to call the police
department and the police are who
removed the children from the home and
put the children
someplace deemed safe until the
investigation can be done so that's
another perception it is not in this
bill it does not give any
entity any more latitude than what the
law already
provides to keep children safe this is
the definitions are
merely helping those
entities parents and the
courts understand the definition of all
of these abusive
behaviors so that you can't be brought
into court and your
child my child did it so my child who is
now almost 50 when she was 12 decided
that I was an abusive parent because I
told her that she had to switch the
toilet every
day and she called child abuse and I I
number it it it is a perception that is
that a gross disgusting job
absolutely but is it child abuse
absolutely not so the perceptions are
what we're trying to clean up and make
finite in this bill and that's what I
hope people take away from this bill
there if you look at the list of
sponsors it is typical of Children and
Family Law committee
that it is not a Democrat bill it is not
a Republican bill it is a good
bipartisan effort to help the children
children and the families of this state
and that's why we're working together to
get this done and get it done
well and and and that's my
perception thank
you thank you I appreciate that you know
I would like to um normally I'd say
elephant but I'll say gorilla in the
room I'd like to talk about the gorilla
in the room there has been question what
if I disagree with my child's religious
choices what if I disagree with their um
orientation um you know and that kind of
stuff is that then if I disagree with
them can they take my kids away what if
my kid is is you know tells me that
they're trans and I say no I disagree
with that is that in itself reason for
them to have an intervention take away
no not at all I will be quite Frank my
son when I was getting threats from a
particular
group that my son decided to say that
that's the political leaning he was he
was um it was a rough moment in time
that was last year I was getting death
threats I was getting threats of getting
feathered and tarred because I said not
all parents are good parents um not only
am I going to stand by that but I'm
going to stand by my son who said that's
his political leaning and did we have a
a disagreement absolutely I mean did I
say how could you do this and did I get
upset yes but the difference is I didn't
take it to the point where now he
trembles when he gets around me and he
wants to talk about it or he curls into
a fetal position if somebody brings up
this particular topic there are levels
you are allowed to disagree with your
kids it's how you go about it that makes
the difference whether or not it's abuse
our children need to understand that not
everybody's going to always agree with
them that's okay but they also need to
understand that they are an individual
who has rights who has entitled to their
own opinions and can make a disagreement
with somebody else that's what we're
raising them for we're raising them to
go out and and think critically in the
world so I think that's very important
to acknowledge too because I do
understand that people have that fear
right now and I
don't as my grandma used to say I want
them to borrow trouble don't have a fear
that you don't have to have um it's just
not a reality that we're looking at with
these
definitions
so Jody do you have any representative
Nelson do you have any input hi yeah
thank you thank you thank you madam
chairwoman um yeah you know just further
um to that there you know there are
clear definitions of what emotional
abuse is I think that representative D
Simon had brought up the last time that
there in in uh law already in New
Hampshire there the other types of abuse
are defined so I think be very helpful
to have that definition as well with you
know um what the definition of emotional
abuse is um I have done a lot of
research and
um Most states now do include some
definition of emotional mental
psychological you know abuse in their
child abuse laws um also too I'm going
to be quite Frank with everybody I was
in involved in a
um emotionally uh and physic
um abusive relationship when I was a
young adult and I think a lot of us um
who have can understand the
statement that I'm going to say I did
have in in the times of when I was
berated for hours I had said hit me
because it would hurt
less as an adult I would say that a
child can't say that and I know because
I've spoken with people and particularly
men who who speak speak about their
severe emotional neglect and abuse
um they you can see that hurt child in
their eyes no matter if they're 30 or 80
so um I
really um I I I hear some of the
concerns I'm not just discounting
that if we're not going to include
emotional abuse in the definition of
child abuse in New Hampshire we are
worrying about what is conjecture to the
result of children here in New Hampshire
and families not getting the help that
they need and Des
deserve that's
good I concur thank you it I couldn't
have said it better thank you
that's very good go ahead have do you
have a proposed amendment or well one
thing that we talked about so I I don't
know if anybody else had a proposed
amendment um but one thing that we did
talk about and that has also come up is
that trauma and form language around um
uh substance abuse disorder we have that
is another concern that we have heard
about I've spent our week off doing a
lot of research um looking at that
substance abuse disorder because I also
o heard that currently
sorry we had People based on what we
have right now we have people afraid to
go seek medical care if they are have
substance abuse disorder and are
pregnant and so they're already afraid
so then it's looking well how can we
make this better so one thing that I do
like about the language that Senator
Carson worked on is that we do talk
about um and first of all this is not in
the the original bill this is the
amendment because the original bill when
it went to OS got
um reevaluated I don't know how to say
that but it was not what we wanted um so
the what we actually wanted is the
amendment that we have and that talks
about the rebuttable presumption of harm
it also talks not about when um the baby
is in utero because that does not fall
under the child protection statute until
the baby is born um but we do want to
acknowledge that harm can come if a
child is substance uh has is substance
exposed but that can't be the only thing
that counts as neglect because we also
understand that there are a lot of
parents when they find out they're
pregnant they decide you know that's it
they want to they want to end that and
stuff so they are struggling with trying
to get to that next step I think it's
important that we have in here that if
um they are monitored by a licensed
healthc care provider which by the way
there is not a timeline on that it
doesn't say the whole nine months it
doesn't say it just says that and I
think that's an important um when this
bill goes through I think that would be
important um thing for people to note to
hopefully help them to want to get
medical care and get that provider
involved because if a provider is um
monitoring them then that falls under
the exemption here that we understand
that what that there are a lot of
nuances to substance abuse disorder and
that we understand that people are
trying to get help and should not be
penalized they should not be unfairly
looked at right now it is my
understanding that because we do not
have anything in there and because we
are all mandated reporters if someone
would come and say have a baby that's
been substance um exposed it is a an
automatic screen in because there is not
um any kind of exception right now so if
that gets called in which there's
nothing telling the doctors not to at
this point because in law because we're
all mandated reporters so I think that's
important to note as well um and trying
to do once again right by the children
we do understand the complications that
children have um so we do have more
trauma inform form language for that
particular section that we discussed did
anybody else have anything for an
amendment um on any of this
the
definition we need to add uh as
representative um Nelson said I think we
need to add uh the specific definition
for emotional abuse um I I I don't think
what we have is specific enough to
properly cover it okay um I'd like to
call the I know office of child advocate
is here and I'd like to call them up
about that uh
definition why it's not in there can we
um and then DCF to I don't know we don't
have four chairs but you guys would be
you're fine sorry to like call you up
it's like you don't want the teacher to
call on you apologize so I know we
talked about defining emotional abuse
during um eight weeks of weekly two to
threeh hour long sessions with Senator
Carson um and you know
Senator Ganon was also Senator
representative McMahon was also there um
we in looking at all the other
states rather than defining emotional
abuse or emotional neglect it was more
the way it currently is
that abuse or neglect was being defined
as the mental emotional psychological so
through all those conversations and and
maybe uh Susan or Jen remember more
distinctly we ended up going kind of
back and forth but not putting in a
specific definition of emotional abuse
or neglect
because you know we didn't Al we also
didn't Define mental abuse or neglect or
you know psychological abuse or neglect
the that sort of list of words is what
the abuse or neglect is so I think the
decision had been made rather than get
into the weeds and defining every single
one of those um but we could certainly
um talk about it where we did Focus was
the definition of psychological
maltreatment which again is actually
coming back to more of the examples like
representative D simonia just gave about
the belittling so I think that's how we
kind of ended up resolving that issue
that most of the concerns and examples
we were hearing actually were defined in
that psychological maltreatment which
was already a definition in there that's
not new but the language became a lot
clearer like what you're saying of sort
of those specific examples and that was
language we pulled from a couple of
other states it had actually been a
longer list during those many many hours
of committee hearings in the fall we
deleted one that we were afraid may go
too far so it it was really an evolution
of that language and rather than Define
the sort of emotional piece um we
focused on that psychological
maltreatment which is um
at the bottom of page six of the
25A if I can read roman numerals which
is possible not um so that was really
where we'd Focus that piece because that
is where sort of the demeaning
threatening
humiliating um which seems to be the
examples everyone gives when they're
thinking emotional it's really
psychological so um that is sort of how
we landed with that other committee
after a lot of
conversations um and then within serious
impairment emotional was already in
serious impairment so that's the middle
of page seven serious impairment is
another place where we really were
striving to be a little bit more exact
because if you look at the definition of
neglect it's the enumerated plus serious
impairment or likely to cause serious
impairment so it's not just the
definition of GCT that goes hand inand
with serious impairment so serious
impairment was another piece and that
was where we'd seen a lot of gaps in
cases that had come to the oca's
attention um either the division or the
courts sort of trying to get into the
nuance and nitty-gritty of what was
serious impairment in some cases
including those severely injured infants
that we were seeing gaps where um you
know the division might think we have a
solid case and a court or or somewhere
else saying me you don't quite meet
serious impairment so those were the two
places we tried to focus on to build out
the nuance and Clarity um rather than
try and defined emotional abuse or
neglect because then you're starting to
like do you define mental abuse do you
def you know it got a little bit too um
detailed but we did definitely talk
about that a lot and go back and forth
on it a lot so hopefully looking at
serious impairment together with neglect
and then that psychological maltreatment
which is really underutilized currently
I was a former dcyf attorney and there
were lots of cases that we felt did rise
to the level of psychological Mal
treatment sort of what you're talking
about representative Nelson of just the
berating that's almost worse than the
physical we would see in cases and in
psychological Mal treatment was very
rarely used because it was just really
hard to prove um so that was a gap we
had seen and in cases um but certainly
if on the emotional AB if I can add in
in looking at different emotional abuse
um definitions across the country in
different states there was a lot of
bringing it back to um emotional injury
and it was talking about an injury as
you know an incident and defined event
um and in really digging deeper into
that it we found that that could
actually um reduce the amount of of
supported allegations or or calls to the
agency if you have it so strictly
defined because it's hard to then Define
that injury and there was a lot of
conversation in the committee as well
about well would that have to be
something that a doctor then diagnoses
that an injury actually occurred um you
know a therapist or a counselor as
opposed to a medical doctor and a lot of
questions around is that going to hold
up if we're looking for a specific
injury versus spreading it in these
other areas to catch more of it because
that would be a high cost to the state
if you're having to hire experts for
every single case um so you know there's
a Supreme Court case of it's around
point ography but you know you know it
when you see it it's real hard to Define
but in sort of the totality of the
circumstances um so that's why we we try
to put that clarifying language in
places um without raising the bar so
high that now and we' had a case where a
child had been um physically assaulted
by a caregiver received a black eye and
a court had said oh that's not serious
impairment because the black eye heals
but being physically assaulted to that
extent by your primary caregiver is a
different type of injury that is
difficult to Define because the the fear
um like you were talking about
representative Greg of you can have a
disagreement it's when your kid flinches
every time you walk into the room but
that's very hard to Define um so that
super hello thank you for your thank you
for your answer um I also um my I have a
representative Rice gave me a nickname
I'm the late night researcher because if
I can't sleep on researching and sending
her
stuff um and I think that feedback that
I've just gotten from other legislators
and concerned um constituents is that in
our law in our rsas now like literally
it would say physical abuse is blah
right so I I definitely see what you're
saying but I think it's hard for people
to kind of get
around that it's not a
specific you
know
um definition to refer to like some
other types of abuse in RSA and
um I know also in other states like for
where did I say for example um well
never mind because I just clicked out of
it I don't want to waste our time but um
there are other definitions that um
are um I'm sorry uh if you could just
please hold on one second I think it is
here otherwise um I can return to it
later
um it was more um less um what you were
talking about and more of uh defining um
it as something that is Habitual you
know um and being vague like that um
um that's all and I think that's that is
sort of the language that ended up in
psychological maltreatment is that it
did require a pattern of threatening de
meaning humiliated which may include but
not be limited too and then gave very
specific examples and I think this
language came directly from Colorado
maybe or maybe been Connecticut some
examples yeah so and that was and again
so that's in psychological
maltreatment but maybe that's a
definition of
emotional abuse I mean I I guess you
know the words but it's talking about
belittling Terror terrorizing
threatening abandonment or harm um
exposure to criminal activities it is
sort of a a laundry list can I just do a
followup I'm just trying to get this
bill passed you know and there are a lot
of legislators that have a problem that
we don't have some sort of definition so
do we combine those two together and you
know um so I that maybe is something
on okay so in
research types of emotional child abuse
rejection ignoring shaming or
humiliating terrorizing and
isolating and
gaslighting
so why can't
we I mean I just
why can't we just put that in there
rejection telling a child they are
worthless unwanted or
unloved ignoring failing to respond to a
child's emotional needs or withholding
affection shaming or humiliating
constantly criticizing belittling or
making a child feel ashamed terrorizing
using threats yelling or intimidating
Behavior to control a child isolating
keeping a child away from friends family
we did incate l oh I'm sorry I was not
um the bottom of page two under the
definition of abuse and it's hard to
read Because all the cross outs but we
did Define emotional harm under abuse
and includes that psychological see I
knew psychological Mal treatment was
reference so that was how we built in so
emotional harm is defined under abuse
paragraph B and it incorporates um that
psychological maltreatment that I was
reading which is similar language but I
like that language you were reading uh
representative right too so certainly
there could be um tweaks to it but we so
we did try and Define emotional Herm
it's
there yeah we have so I have something
actually just forward to you um uh that
has a it it defines each like ver what
verbal abuse is constant criticism or
each of the like seven parts that they
have defined officially as emotional
abuse um and I I'll forward that to all
of you as well maybe that's something
that we if you really feel strongly that
we need to be more specific with this
because certainly if this is going to
upend a very important bill I can't
stress enough how important this is
we've been trying to get this updated
for ages so if this is something yeah go
ahead
hi and I'm sorry I don't know why I said
taking hi oh gosh
it's um it I'm trying to um streamline
um issues with family
court and parents not understanding
certain parts of law regarding to family
court and um I think that by being vague
in
describing um this kind of thing
honestly doesn't give a fair shake to
the parents you know they might not
might not understand specifically what
they've done wrong by law and to have it
be deter determined by somebody they
might feel is being
subjected
subjective
um you know I don't I don't know if
that's
ahead I'm agreeing with that 100% saving
a
few key strokes is not going to save a
child I remember a person that used to
come to our committee representative
rice will remember him the poor man had
just absolutely no idea that what he had
done was
wrong
he it w it was a horrible thing to his
child when he thought nothing about
going up to her with his hands touching
her and saying oh you're almost as big
as your
mother he meant in his mind
[Music]
nothing bad about that he had no idea
how
[Music]
inappropriate that was he had absolutely
no idea and that in many other reasons
his children were removed from his
home and he used to come to our
committee and say they took my kids for
no reason I asked him to bring his
transcripts of the tri
he and I sat for an hour and a half
going over them and I pointed out to him
at that point how inappropriate the
behavior
was and he
said
oh now how come it doesn't say that in
the
law that's the point of these
definitions this particular person may
God Rest his soul
had no
idea that what he was doing was wrong he
had no idea the effect that it had on
his children none and that's what we're
hearing a lot of is that they just don't
get it in this bill if this does not
pass and it is not
specific like representative Nelson said
then we have not done on our job MH I
agree and I think that's really common
for um people who are probably caught up
in Cycles you know passed down from
generations of what they think is
appropriate um you know they don't have
that insight into their own behavior and
of course we have mental health issues
and other things so there are some some
hiccups in our system for sure yes um
just speaking as a lawyer who you know
for my whole career works with language
and and and what
what covers things from the point of
view of Prosecuting cases and or or
getting DC involved and uh the way the
better and giving also giving notice I
I'm supportive of the idea of having a
list but I'm also supportive of changing
the language that you see all the time
in the law which may include but is not
limited to you know that kind of we
don't want the list to be
uh exclusive I think instead of having
which may include but it's not limited
to language you need a a a subparagraph
that says some version of and and I can
you know later today I can write it up
if it's valuable to anyone some version
of
uh the exam the examples given in this
statute are just examples it's not an
exclusive list
and there there may well be other
behavior that uh it falls within this I
think that kind of notice to parents
would be more explicit than the language
everybody ignores including but not
limited to it would be I think that we
run the risk when we start giving
examples is that there's no way we can
list the millions of examples that we
have so I think I understand and I hear
the need for a specific definition um
for those of you that um at DCF and
office of child I've sent you um maybe
something in all of you something that
we can kind of start from and say could
this work um this is a standard
definitions of what emotional abuse
looks like I certainly don't want to
upend anything in here but I do see the
need that I think we're going to have to
have another subcommittee meeting to be
honest
unless
are yeah are we yeah so so we'll need an
amendment did you just send it I sent
yeah and that's what um representative
pone think should go in um and then we
could include the language of may
include but not limited
to again I would I would recommend a
better language than that instead of
having the language uh may include but
it's not limited to I would I would say
for example and then have the list and
then at the end of the list say these
are only examples
um well we can have we can we can have a
motion to have an amendment but not have
the full Amendment language right now so
I move that we have an amendment okay if
I may add second okay A bit of context
as well um we did I just want to share
from the prior committee work um we did
have a longer list that one under here I
believe it may have been the seven that
that you had that you have shared with
us um and it was parsed down a bit
because there were a lot of questions
about um some of the the belittling
aspects and really wanting to ensure
that it stays at that um real high level
that's fitting abuse and not those
parents that are you know just
threatening their their child that
you're going to be in trouble if type of
situation so um this list under
psychological maltreatment is parsed
down after those many commit meetings in
the fall um so I just wanted to make
sure that as we look at it again we may
have to have some further conversations
or we may be able to share some context
with you all about which ones we were
asked to parse down by that committee
already and and I can also the including
but not limited to language and and
again U we we had all talked about that
I in criminal law I know it's it's much
less common it's got to be very exact
and clear for criminal uh penalties but
you know with child welfare and social
work while we want it to be clear and
transparent for parents to know I think
there is a certain amount of once you
start listing things anything not on
that list is fine and if you start
listing every single thing it it it does
become it's going to be a 300 page long
statute
so a lot of the conversations we had in
the fall also with Senator Carson and
subcommittee
was building that trust in the child
welfare system that these are trained
social workers going into a home and you
never know what you're going to find and
the thing that got called in might not
be the worst thing you find when you set
foot in that home and so there was
conversations with various players of
how because this whole statute is about
protecting children and being able to
have that little bit of leeway so it
really was sort of trying to find
that gray area of that the statute is
clear to make sure you're not getting
called in for sending your kid do their
room or clean their room but also
allowing the the child protection
workers who are The Trusted
Professionals in this field the the
latitude to protect children um and some
of those gaps we found were places where
where you know the division already felt
that they knew that this was abuse or
neglect but that the law was not sort of
allowing them to offer services um so
Clarity is great especially as an
attorney we like things to say exactly
what we mean for them to say but we also
do want to find that line to allow when
you walk into a situation some latitude
to be able to protect the children in
that home um because it could be
something completely unrelated going
on so would
you speak a little bit about if the
verbage was in there that said shall be
to and and that's the verbiage that is
currently used in the current statute
and in many other states and I I'd be
interested of Representative U Nelson
what what you found on your exhaustive
review of States it's it's hard to make
a law that you want to allow some wiggle
room to protect children but you want to
be clear without using that language and
I think what um Cassandra was just
saying is we really parsed out it's in
the psychological maltreatment section
but we could certainly move it to make
it clearer
um that that was sort of a laundry list
with specific examples and you know it
included trafficking and there was a lot
of language in there um and Senator
Carson and her committee did purse some
of it out as kind of addressing some of
the fears that were being felt um but I
mean I guess language that this is these
are just examples but that's no clearer
if you're just saying here's a bunch of
examples but those aren't all of them
it's it's really just the same way to
say including but not limited to so I I
I'd be open if you have other language
or or whatever that that that is the the
problem you're trying to address the for
example I I the only reason I brought up
the four example language is we all I
certainly as a lawyer they as lawyers
all of you who've worked on drafting and
legislation like this we all understand
what including but not limited to means
I think that language just goes right by
people's head who are reading it so I
you know the for example language
uh the people the parents who who are
subject to this understand that it's
just a language thing but I think it's
an important one the for example
language what I I believe it was EG to
begin with the I don't know if what you
read it had an EG which EG is even worse
that so I just need to remind everyone
that everything has to go through the
chair okay that is out of respect for
her so these conversations you can't
just speak up like that she is the
chairwoman okay thank
you thank you um I think you know the
more that I hear and and I did pour over
the um
uh Senator Carson's work their committee
and certainly this was a lot of ours um
representative McMahon is on our
committee you know he worked very hard
on that I think what happens is and this
is pretty typical in today's society is
that our first shot at this came out OS
did not give us back what we gave them
and you know that led to some
misconceptions certainly out in the
public um and then those that little
that little snowflake it turns into a
snowball and then we continue on so a
lot of this is having these
conversations to help people understand
what this is and what this is not this
is not in any way punitive this is not
in any way um you know the
final say on now you get your kids taken
away or anything else and we've already
discussed this but I don't think it can
be said enough so I understand with
specific language and I did read in
their report why they did not get so
specific with some of that because part
of this is in the training these are
bills that we also have you know what
does training look like what does um you
know what
uh what um gosh what I can't think I'm
can't think of it right now uh what DCF
is able to do what the office of the
child advocate what they're directed to
do all of these things fall in line This
is not while this is a foundation this
is not the end all on what we're going
to do with it certainly things come
after that so I do want to be super min
ful because I do know that they talked
about why they didn't have um things
listed and it really is because of you
know because they did have that in there
first I think actually representative
McMahon was one that you know was
talking about that pretty specifically
and also came to the realization that
when they started doing that there was
an issue so I think that we could look
at if there's something more specific or
putting it in a different area what is
already defined that's the other thing
too when we look at this this bill I
think sometimes people see one section
of it and you really have to read it in
its entirety and I know that you all
have I know that you've done your due
diligence on that and I appreciate all
of your work on that um and and that's
part of our our issue right now but
certainly if we you know can maybe
outline it in another section as well
that would be good but um I do think we
have agreement that we need an amendment
certainly we want to have more trauma in
form language that's um we want to be
sensitive to that um and I think that we
could um look the definitions with
office of child advocate this week if um
representative deimon and Nelson if you
wanted to talk to them and then you
could put forth the amendment if you'd
like um if you come up with one I just I
know that we're all hearing from a lot
of different sources and we're getting a
lot of different emails and a lot of the
fears that we're hearing are unfounded I
will say that they are just you know
misconceptions about what we have here
so um you know it's it's hard to put it
all it's that toothpaste it's hard to
put all back in the tube once it's out
but we're trying to figure out how to
mitigate this for people because I don't
want people to be afraid they're going
to lose their kids we have a lot of
really great parents in the granite
state and we have a lot of parents who
want to be great parents um but they
just need the help to become great
parents and so I want to make sure that
we're including all of them did you have
something and I would just like to um
reiterate that this is about
intervention right they're not coming in
to take your children if you if they see
that you you need help or guidance in an
area they can provide those services to
you but they're not coming in to rip
your children out these are the days of
the old system we have done so much work
over the years to keep families together
because we know that that's what's best
for those kids even the most abused
child will want to stay with their
parent and sometimes can do more harm to
pull them out of that home than to keep
them in it so these are things that we
have to remember you know there were the
old days these are the new days where we
are focusing on keeping families
together I
you I Echo those sentiments exactly the
good news/bad news is that people are
really being being focused on um that
one
section and I say good news bad news the
bad news is people don't have a
conception as to actually what emotional
abuse is and the reason for that is
because most people don't see it they
don't see the result in the child you
cannot always see a broken heart the
good news is that we do have specific
criteria that we can amend the bill to
speak
to we as a society many many many of us
are coming out of a generation where all
of this abuse was so
prevalent we didn't even know we were
being
abused so if what how many of you here
well I turned out all right uh Maybe not
maybe not so much I was a hot mess
before therapy Bingo as was I as was I
so if we can pass this bill which and it
it's the same as what we're dealing with
right now with kids who are involved in
um a multitude of issues like drug
addiction and um violence and being
thieves and whatnot when we started
having
um agencies that would put kids through
challenge
programs a and so forth and so on we
started teaching the children in a nice
way an easy to understand way their
behavior was wrong and now the state's
focus is more on
intervention so if we have this bill
definition zero
consequences in this bill because the
consequences if you break the law are
already there but understanding that
this is all for
intervention it it it is
then we go to the
prevention and and that's what this is
about so I agree with you there and I
think that a small
Amendment to the bill
to just
Define the emotional abuse
aspect but not limited
to will bring
us right into this
century and it it's going to help the
kids stay with their parents and it's
going to help
parents be able to love and and adore
more um so thank you and I think that we
will be talking to you so we already
have um a motion in a second to have an
amendment um before we can close though
so we do understand that we're going to
be working on this and and have that
before we have the um
exact session on it it's a Monday um lot
going got lot going through my head um
we do need a motion on how we feel about
this bill whether our recommendation
will be OTP otpa so we'll have to have a
motion in a second and a vote on
thepa okay vpa second okay um all in
favor I all opposed okay so that will be
our recommendation um thank you all this
has been hundreds of hours for
I think we're over a hundred people now
and we are really trying to get it right
um for the kids so and that's really the
the basis of our uh committee is to get
it right for the kids and make sure that
we are doing our best for them um and I
thank you all and we will see you soon
thank that concludes the session are you
put
together we will do one with everything
y
e
committee
is
e